[Music]
do you guys know
jojo siwa yeah she is no who is that is
she the
like um the colorful girl yes the
colorful girl so she
energy i always call it anne frank but
i'm so wrong what
lisa anne frank is completely i know i
always say
it's the opposite of the colorful one i
know it's the sad one
you think in his mind he goes oh lisa
frank the girl is stuck in the annex
diary what is going on and frank it was
austria germany or something right
uh it was amsterdam because when we were
in amsterdam
i know well it had to do with world war
ii so that's why
and in world war ii in the nazis and
whatever no until we were in amsterdam
yeah i didn't know
i would have thought it was in germany
no no but then she's saying i'm flipping
it right [ __ ] jojo's
whatever so so it's like i'm out there
and i'm anne frank world and i'm like oh
lisa frank
and paul frank's a monkey oh yeah that's
right and frank ocean is awesome
so jojo siwa she's a 17 year old singer
and you're 17 now she's 17. she when she
was 16 like three four you should be 18
by now
well according to the cnn article she's
17.
so i don't know her real life but 15 in
2016.
is she still a rainbow she she embodies
a rainbow
she's a she's a tuber yes so she
is youtube she gained popularity because
of the show dance moms
she was on that show so anyway so she
recently came out with an apology video
type of thing
so there's this controversy thing
happening here where
there's a nickelodeon branded game
like a board game that which is marketed
to children aged six and older
and it's called jojo's juice so it's
used
it's using her name in an image and
so it's this board game here that
apparently is kind of like a truth or
dare kind of
board game and so this chit or this
mom she ended up posting on on facebook
she said if your child has this jojo
game
i think it belongs in the trash i am
just what in the actual
look at these questions dares etcetera
this
world is sick really and so she
what did they say is truth or dare like
when did you lose your virginity
and it's like a six-year-old well
hopefully they don't have an answer
exactly this one it says
have you ever walked in on someone naked
or had someone walk in on you
oh that's one six and up
this other one says who made this game i
hope not a pedophile well we're walking
on naked
taika quite a bit yeah that's pretty
pretty commonplace
yeah so then this other one says have
you ever stolen from a store
yeah another one says have you ever gone
outside without underwear parentheses a
bathing suit doesn't count
ooh these are that's not good kissed a
boy
have you ever kissed a boy uh learned
the art of twerking
okay i feel like if this was a game for
senior citizens it'd be really funny it
would be yeah
those are good questions 65 and up yeah
65
doesn't sound right for six year olds
right well let me finish a few
few more what's 60 years old like uh
first grade yeah yeah
no kindergarten or depending around
there i couldn't even read at that age
that's just too bad you're killing it so
another one says have you ever taken
money from someone's purse or wallet
without
asking and then the dare is but then if
you hear grandma say yes you're like
yeah exactly
it makes it much funnier you're right
bar dare says rub noses with the person
on your left
like another one says have you ever been
arrested
and this last one i have here is who in
this room would you most like to date
did they just be lazy with this and
print out like a truth or dare kind of
card stack and it just branded it with
like jojo siwa and nickelodeon [ __ ] and
just sell it
yeah they think anyone under like 13 or
under 16
is like the same age so like six it up
sure
yeah love to think that this got
approved on every level by every person
and they're all like yes that's a great
idea stamped and approved
they were more into the marketing aspect
than actually reading what the game was
about exactly
so then jojo she posted this
this video wow she's so happy she's
always
she's happy as [ __ ] no i know but if
you're issuing an apology that's just
not the expression i
expect to see that's all i'm saying hey
everyone it's jojo so
over the weekend has been lost my
attention by my fans and followers on
tick tock
that my name and my image have been used
to promote this board game
that has some really inappropriate
content now when companies make these
games
they don't run every aspect by me and so
i had no
idea of the types of questions that were
on these playing cards
now when i first saw this i was really
really really upset at how gross these
questions were
and so i brought it to nickelodeon's
attention immediately and since then
they have been working to get this game
stop being made and also pulled from all
shelves wherever it's being sold
i hope you all know that i would have
never ever ever approved or agreed to be
associated with this game if i would
have seen these cards
before they started selling it i love
you all so much thank you for bringing
this to my attention so that way i could
put a stop to it and i could get it
fixed immediately
i love you all so much and i hope you
have an awesome 2021.
she's an alien because her the sound is
getting to me before
her mouth moves i don't know how she
does it it's her doing that
yep it's her fault ps all my products in
the future
i probably won't know that much about
them
if you see those kind of cards coming
out from me you know it wasn't me
because mine would be much crazier oh i
know that you would have sat there and
read every single card like this dude
don't even worry about it yeah i don't
know if she promoted it
yeah because like you would think she
she would she's big enough that she
should have a lawyer review things
before putting her name on it right yeah
but it's also like
nickelodeon so maybe they thought this
is this is nobody was reading
is what happened nobody did their
[ __ ] job and it was a [ __ ] holiday
i guarantee that's what happened white
label [ __ ] product
or the existing game i bet you we can
find the same exact game
that's true that's like with the same
questions
for the same age group for a different
age group different like it might be
like
like truth or dare for teens or [ __ ]
college kids or whatever right
and then they're just like oh we'll just
put a picture on it and [ __ ] resell
it and they probably try to rush it out
before the haul
or before the holiday did you guys play
girl talk no
no what is that girl talk was like
exactly like this but
it was i mean just set up differently
for 12 and up i think though
pretty inappropriate too yeah it was
like hey don't you want to date a boy at
the mall it was all about dating boys
and calling boys and pranking boys and
if you didn't do it you had to put a zit
sticker on oh no
what a bummer yeah this game was from
the 90s you know what i always wanted
but my parents didn't get me
skip it i had it i wanted to skip it
i you just spin that [ __ ] around that's
nothing
the real [ __ ] was the easy bake oven oh
that's what i [ __ ] wanted that was
and they're like you want that i need to
do that [ __ ] in the kitchen
i got that for christmas when i was like
20 because i
had told my boyfriend at the time that i
always wanted one and he got me one well
i hope one day
i'll have a girlfriend that will get get
one wait you didn't you didn't make it i
didn't i didn't
never use it the [ __ ] light bulb is
hard to find you really do just say
you want to do [ __ ] don't you we
couldn't find the [ __ ] light bulb you
even
get the gratitude from just getting it
and then she doesn't have to do anything
with it unbelievable
it's like she's like i want this car and
then because we didn't have the damn
light bulb
as long as you ask for it and then you
get it you don't even have to use it
you're fine with it so you're good you
should be a museum curator i still
wanted to use it
i like i said i couldn't find the light
bulb and i was really bummed out
bummed out about it is it a special
light bulb so he got it for you but he
didn't get the light bulb yeah
that's too bad that's like getting a
walkie-talkie with no batteries how dare
you
on christmas day i know dude oh that was
the worst
yeah but so you always wanted what same
thing
oh right so maybe i'll get a boyfriend
one day that'll buy it for me but then
this time i'll get the light bulb yeah
you get that lighter this thing called
creepy crawlers oh
baby crawlers but i was bummed that you
couldn't eat it
i thought i thought it was made out of
gummies well i got the one you can't eat
i got the one the knockoff one yeah i
got the one that is like
it's plastic and so you're like like i
can't eat it this sucks oh that's too
bad
the creepy growlers these creepy collars
you could eat because you the dirt was
made out of like chocolate oreo dust or
whatever
was it i remember seeing the commercial
be like i want that and then my mom
brought me the one with the plastic
oh i thought you form your own creepy
crawlers with like
different gels yeah and it hardens yeah
damn so i didn't have creepy crawlers i
think i had the i had the cvs knock-off
version you had museum crawlers
it was not good silly putty is it called
silly buddy they're silly putting
ender's gack they're different though
okay oh the one that you can make it
fart when you go like
you can make both of them both sunlight
could do that
well i feel like silly putty came in the
egg like on that dark harder
yeah and then gat came in this the slime
splat because the putty you could put on
newspaper and then like it'll transfer
yeah yeah
did you guys have squand what's it was
very limited edition but
okay so it's colorful sand but it never
gets wet
so you put it in you put it in the
aquarium and you can mold it and shape
it and you can make all kinds of sand
castles and stuff
but then when you take it out it's sand
again and it's dry oh
i remember seeing those commercials yeah
wait is it like the sand that
molds together uh yeah i mean it melts
together in the water
well in the water so they've always made
a castle and then they would make it
there was another one that had the
little styrofoam balls in it
do you guys remember that one that you
could shape things that it has like a
little tiny styrofoam
oh yeah yeah yeah that was the
nickelodeon one right yeah
these are all like nickelodeon ones i
think i do like the sand that's kind of
like
semi-moist and then you can form things
with it and has a good texture
but it's never dry and dusty yeah has
that like kinetic sand
yeah yeah yeah yeah is that what it's
called kinetic sand yeah we have that
there's so many fun things man what are
some fun toys that
that you've discovered now with like a
little toddler i didn't know that a
bottle could be so fun
watching him play with one yeah like
that oh like legitimate
yeah i know oh um so right now it's
really cool because he
doesn't like he'll say he's starting to
be like that's for girls that's what i'm
like i don't give a [ __ ] we're getting
it anyway there's no such thing you feel
like you like it
so it's like i just got him this camping
set and it comes with the big little
tennis
[ __ ] and then it comes with like fake um
wood and then like
a little campfire and he has a little
lantern and i'm like yo this is [ __ ]
he said that's for girls no no no no but
like i have to like
change that so then i got him a kitchen
because he wanted a kitchen but then he
goes no i don't want it that's for girls
i'm like no it's not we're getting the
[ __ ] kitchen so now you're getting
the kitchen now you're playing and damn
kids playing the kitty play in the
kitchen
he loves the kitchen he loves cooking at
first he was like that's for girls
yeah where did he get that i think he
watches the kids youtube
and then they'll probably stay here yeah
does he like play camping he loves
he goes in his tent he brings his
lantern in and then he has a fake
campfire even though
the wood comes like this i think i could
do this kind of camping this sounds fun
yeah you'd love it yeah yeah you'd love
it um yeah i mean just anything for
adults now they make it for kids like
i've always wanted a power wheel so like
i'm
now that he has one i play i mean i'm
like living vicariously through him
because he'll like he has a little jeep
and he's like going off-roading and
stuff and i'm like
i always wanted that i'm glad you have
it that's something i got what i wanted
i always wanted the power wheels
batmobile that was so
sick i'm getting that for our kid no
matter if it's boy or girl i'll be like
i don't care your [ __ ] batgirl
get in the goddamn car i had the i had
the i had the atv
the yellow one how fun
[Music]
you